[Music]
the psychotic a Trump media mob they're
scrambling after a shake-up at NBC NBC
News sees soon-to-be former chairman
Andy luck is out trace Gallagher
standing by live our West Coast newsroom
with a report Wow New York Attorney
General Chris Matthews Matt Lauer Andy
lack a lot of big names there and Shawn
we thought the departure of any lack was
the true bombshell here until
investigative reporter rich McHugh told
Tucker Carlson that the New York
Attorney General is investigating NBC
News litany of sexual harassment
complaints while lack was at the helm
rich McHugh worked at NBC as Ronan
Pharos producer and you'll recall it was
Andy lack who refused to air Pharos
expose on the sexual assault allegations
against Harvey Weinstein saying it
wasn't fit for air so Ronan Farrow took
it to the New Yorker and won a Pulitzer
it was also Andy lack who decided the
sexual misconduct allegations against
Matt Lauer should be investigated by
fellow NBC executives instead of outside
investigators NBC News told us it's not
aware of any inquiry by the New York
Attorney General which is odd
considering former NBC correspondent and
Fox News anchor Linda Wester says the
New York AG's office interviewed her
about the investigation three months ago
Sean uh yeah I tend to believe them
that's my thing all right Tracy
Gallagher will follow that story